what's different about Android pay how
customers benefit well Android pay is
going to provide a that makes it very
easy to do in-app purchases and also
terminal purchases so this builds on
what we've seen from other ecosystem
players who want to make it simple and
easy to pay and interact with their
devices now one of the problems with
Android devices that is that people
browse don't buy and that's something
that Google is trying to change how does
the way people shop on Android phones
differ from the way people shop on
iPhones well I think Apple had come out
with Apple pay as a medium to make it
simple and easy and faster to pay with
native apps on their devices and so now
Google is looking for a similar
experience to make it just as easy on
their platform and make it so that
commerce can be more streamlined in
those platforms mobile as a whole is a
place where merchants and consumers are
both looking for new ways to connect
more easily while there is so much
browsing activity as you said on these
mobile devices there's far less
purchasing activity because it's
generally just been more difficult to do
that but with Apple pay in the mix and
Android pay and products from players
like us at PayPal as well with our
OneTouch product we're all trying to
simplify that that system and make it so
that merchants can benefit by having
more streamlined ways to offer their
products now one I want to bring in our
editor at large Cory Johnson who's been
at Google i/o all day long
Cory you know it seems like a lot of the
things that Google announced today are
playing catch-up to Apple Android pay
for example some of these voice
recognition features HBO what's your
take on that well I think you're
absolutely right but I think the way
that Google does these things is very
different also I mean really nothing was
announced here today I mean a new
operating system that everyone knew was
coming and they've given away most the
features of an advanced a photo app I
mean a new version of wallet and and
this pay thing that's similar what
wallet was so but that's Google
Google works in with with a series of
producers of their handsets they work
with many manufacturers of things Apple
works with one manufacturer of thing
it's Apple so really it's a very
different kind of ecosystem that they're
trying to support so the nature of an
event like this well it's a place where
developers want to come to find out the
very latest the exciting look I just
went into a session in there we're
developers were learning about when to
have a notification button and how you
should program such a button that's a
very different thing than announcing a
new iPhone but that's where Google is
and that's the kind of thing that
they're trying to get done and so maybe
giant product announcements just aren't
their thing you know talking about this
one click pay purchase one it's
something that Amazon has been doing for
a very long time do we know that it
actually increases the frequency by
which people buy yeah it does and
actually we've been doing one-click
purchases on the Braintree platform for
mobile apps for a long time as well
powering that for the likes of uber and
hotelTonight and others and it's much
easier to have stored payment
credentials that consumers don't have to
enter every time they purchase so that
they can do that one-click purchase
every time when you're booking that uber
ride or that hotel tonight stay now Cori
I want to hear more about this cardboard
virtual reality device of course you and
I have tried oculus is this thing the
real deal yeah
so you know virtual rail is a really
cool word this thing is really cool
dildo case has had this thing out for a
while we've to take your iphone slap it
in and there are certain videos or
things that Google but it's levity in
these eyepiece and you could see things
kind of virtually and look around have a
different experience
very clever sup this thing's a little
bit better it's similar to oculus it's
not completely immersive but similarly
you could look at something that's in
front of you turn to your right see
something different here right turn your
left see double something different in
your left and then come up with new ways
to capture that but it's it's a
fascinating step in the direction of
trying to figure out what to do with
these new capabilities of chips that can
calculate the movement on a device
widely available devices and cheap
cameras to shoot the things but it's
just a step in that direction I think
we're gonna see things along those lines
but there's a use case as still is is
greatly lacking there but it's
interesting and cool stuff nonetheless
now Corey no surprise skydiving events
no surprise QA from Larry Page as there
has been in the past it's been about
eight months now since he passed over a
lot of the control to sundar pichai who
led a lot of today's presentations
what's your take on on how well sundar
is stewarding Google at this point it is
possible that the all-time highlight of
Google i/os will be the time that that
Sergey parachuted in I mean all we've
got now is Sebastian Thrun
jetting around in a skateboard you know
I don't you saw that with him jetting
around behind me but yeah look the the
ceremony of these events we've gotten to
a point now where every CEO of a major
corporation fielding they've got to be
Steve Jobs they've got to take off their
necktie they've got to give an
inspirational speech in front of a
fevered crowd of employees and some
users and that's how products should be
announced that wasn't always the way
with product announcements it probably
won't always really be the way in the
future but I think that the adoption of
this mobile technology and the ability
of Android is one of the reasons why
this event is important that for
developers if not if